OK, we're on problem
number 16.
Let's see, they drew
us something here.
From point A to point
B, I have a line.
Then I have another, B to C.
Then I have another,
from here to here.
OK, so what are they
telling us?
They tell us, this is
a 90 degree angle.
Whoops, not what I wanted
to do, edit, undo.
I'm using the wrong tool.
So they tell us, this is a 90
degree angle, this is 90
degree angle.
This is A, this is B, this
is C, this is D.
And they say, the figure above
shows the route of Diane's
trip from her house
to her job.
Diane travels 16 miles from
A to B, so this is 16.
15 miles from B to
C, so this is 15.
And 4 miles from C to
D, so this is 4.
If she were to travel from
A to D directly, how much
shorter in miles would
the trip be?
So what would be the
direct route?
I'm assuming, they're kind of
talking if she could fly.
What would be her
direct route?
So that would be this route.
I thought I was using
the line tool.
Edit, undo.
I'll do it in a better
color anyway.
So this is the direct
route, right here.
This is we want to figure out,
the distance of this.
So how can we figure
out the distances?
And the trick here is to just
realize that this is going to
be the hypotenuse of
a right triangle.
And you might-- seem confusing,
your initial
impulse might have been to say
this is x, and this is 15
minus x, and all of
this fancy stuff.
Or what you could do, is you can
say, well, this side here,
we know what this
is, this length.
Whoops.
Let me draw it a little
bit better.
That length, what
is that length?
Well, this length is going
to be the same as
this length, right?
If we assume this is
a 90 degree angle.
It's going to be 15.
And then what's this
length, right here?
Well it's going to same as this
length up here, right?
I just kind of extended
a rectangle.
So this length right
here is 4.
So what is this entire length?
It's going to be 16 plus
4, so it's 20.
So now, what we're trying to
figure out, her straight line
distance, is nothing but the
hypotenuse of a rectangle-- of
a right triangle, where we
know the other two sides.
So we can say, if this is her
straight line distance, x, we
could say x squared is equal to
20 squared, 20 squared plus
15 squared.
x squared is equal to-- let's
see, this is 400, plus 225, is
equal to 625.
And the square root of 625 is
25, so x is equal to 25.
So her straight line
distance is 25.
And how far was she
travelling before?
Let's see, she was going
16 plus 15 plus 4.
So that's 20-- she was going
35, what is that, miles?
Right, miles.
She was going 35 miles,
and if she goes
straight, she goes 25 miles.
So she would save 10 miles if
she went straight, if she was
able to fly.
So that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem number 17.
One circle has a radius of 1/2,
and another circle has a
radius of 1.
What is the ratio of the area
of the larger circle to the
area of the smaller circle?
Let's see, so the area of circle
1, area 1, is going to
be equal to what?
It has a radius of 1/2, right?
So it's pi r squared,
is the radius.
So it's pi 1/2 squared.
And what's the area
of circle 2?
The area of circle 2, it's
pi times its radius.
And its radius is 1.
So 1 squared.
So the ratio of the area of
the larger circle to the
smaller circle-- which one is
going to be the larger circle?
This one is, because it has
a larger radius, right?
It has a radius of 1.
So the ratio of the larger
circle to the smaller circle--
and that might be where you
messed up, if you flipped the
two-- the ratio of the larger
circle to the smaller circle
is equal to pi times 1, right?
Well that's just pi.
Over pi times 1/2 squared.
Pi's cancel out, so we have,
it equals 1 over 1/4.
Or what we could do is we could
multiply the numerator
and the denominator by
4, which equals 4/1.
So the ratio is 4:1, and
that's choice D.
Problem 18.
Clear image.
If the sum of the consecutive
integers from minus 22 to x
inclusive is 72, what
is the value of x?
So this is the number-- we've
actually done a problem very,
very similar to this, so it
shows you that people at the
SAT, they think of a lot of
creative problems, but every
now and then, they
have to repeat.
So they're saying the sum of the
consecutive integers from
minus 22 to x is 72.
So let's think about this,
let's draw the sum.
So it's minus 22, plus minus
21, plus minus 20, right?
Plus-- it keeps going, until
it gets to 0-- plus 0.
And then-- and I'm going to go
this way, again, I'm doing
that for a reason.
And then you can say, plus 1,
plus 2, plus-- you keep going,
and then you'd have plus 20,
plus 21, plus 22, plus 23,
plus 24, all the way until
we get to x, right?
What you need to realize is all
the way from minus 22 to
22, the sum is 0.
And why is that?
Well, look at the
way I drew it.
So minus 22-- we're taking the
sum of everything, right?
So minus 22 is going to cancel
out with positive 22.
You add those together,
you get 0.
Minus 21 is going to cancel
out with positive 21.
Minus 20 is going to cancel
out with positive 20.
And so forth, and so on.
So everything-- so the sum from
minus 22 plus, bam, bam,
bam, bam, all the way to plus
22, that equals 0, right?
So we only get into the
positive sum once
we get to 23, right?
So 23 plus 24 plus something,
something,
something, is x, right?
And we have to get to 72.
And here we can just
eyeball it.
23 plus 24 plus 25,
what's that?
Well their average is 24,
24 times 3 is 72.
Or we can just add it up.
So 23 plus 24 is 47, 47
plus 25, it equals 72.
So the last number that we use
in this whole range is 25.
So this is x.
That is x.
And all we did is we said--
think about it, take the sum
from minus 22, all the
way to positive 25.
Everything up to negative 22,
from minus 22 to positive 22,
all of those cancel out
with each other.
So the sum is just going to
be 23 plus 24 plus 25.
That equals 72, so
then x is 25.
Next problem-- I'm running out
of time, so I'd better do it
in the next video.
See you soon.